this has been a moment almost two years
to the making right here engine ryu
pitching as a blue jay at rogers center
for the first time here's the one-two
pits cut out of this another terrific
changeup first out of the game
grace mcguire finally finds the right
pitch
cutter on the outside swinging a miss
good start for ryu back-to-back
strikeouts doesn't have to be inside it
doesn't have to be up but he can back
door too there's a lot of movement on
that cutter here early on in this game
starting pitcher and zach coming off a
win against st louis in his last start
where he went five innings gave up seven
hits a couple of runs the right-hander
is zach pliesek and he'll face the
reigning american league player of the
week george springer
there's a drive left here this ball is
hit hard get up get out of here god how
about another lead-off home run for
george springer his 41st career lead off
home run and the blue jays jump out on
top early he's been swinging a hot bat
he sets that tone for the the offense
early on
bounced off home played tough play for
remiss he unloads in a hurry not in time
pulls bobby bradley off the base it's
going to be an infield hit for bo
michelle two-out base runner for toronto
that'll bring in tay oscar hernandez
fly ball deep to right field get up ball
get out of here and gone he stayed on
that one tay oscar hernandez an opposite
field home run his 17th of the season
and the blue jays have jumped on three
sack here in the first
slight shift to the left
2-2
swinging to miss
third strikeout for ryu
four up and four down
nice way to start the second inning
bradley he got a pinch hit it back in
the game yesterday and he hits this one
high in the air into shallow right
simeon is out second baseman calls for
it and he goes out to make the catch
another quick inning for ryu six up six
down blue jays have a three nothing lead
there's a line drive into center field
that's in front of straw for a base hit
curiel has to stop at second another
great at bat for reese maguire that will
bring george springer to the plate
round ball to short
there's one onto first they turn
and ending ending double play three
nothing in toronto through two
one two pitch
carl's strike three right on the outside
corner
and ryu is locked in man he's got his a
program working tonight early
there's there's
right field by ernie clement and mercado
will stop at second so the indians have
a couple of base hits off ryu here in
the third
rosario goes after the first pitch and
hits it in the air but there's george
springer asari retired on one pitch ryu
strands a couple more faces
a little chopper slogan
he trusts grab it bare hand and valeria
couldn't come up with it and jose
ramirez has the indians
third hit second infield hit of the ball
game not that that would have went far
but he might have
let it go they're going inside now
against reyes
beautiful
boy he had himself gonna have to break
up they got to break out the towel again
he struck out for a second time as he
takes a breaking ball for a call third
strike runner at first two down here's
bobby bradley bobby bradley rifles one
to deep right field
flying around second on his way to third
is big harrell tay oscar comes up with
it they're gonna send him
[Applause]
it home a throw that gets away from the
catcher and the indians steal a run yeah
they were lucky there that throw went
wild
past maguire they are set to bat in the
bottom of the fourth thales hernandez
and a home run his first time up now
he's got a laid off base hit here in the
fourth
the ballers hit high in the air to right
field long run for mercana that's a fair
ball
it's up against the fence and they're
going to hold tayasaka at third
but curiel is two for two if that went a
long way to the opposite field down in
the quarter in right the switch hitting
breivik valera at the plate 1-2
hit on the ground and that's going to
get a run in bolero does a good job of
cashing in to oscar from third and the
blue jays get that run back they now
have a 4-1 lead
there's another slide as we hitting the
gap it's going to be a tough when it
gets down
as ramirez plays it back in and springer
is in sliding with a double
[Applause]
[Music]
marcus sivian drives it into left field
springer is
going to stop as that ball got to the
left field to ramirez very quickly
toronto's in front 4-1 police act to
beau bashet
bar hit in the air not that deep straw
backing under it
tagging at third and coming home is
springer and the throw is not in time
bob is shed with a sacrifice fly
as george springer tagged and slides in
safely ahead of the throw simeon moved
up on the play so he's at second forte
oscar hernandez ground ball up the
middle that'll get through simeon is
around third he's going to score
have a night te
oscar three for three with three ribbies
boy that was another good at bat he just
stayed on that ball and went right back
up the middle for a base hit
that's in the gap
nobody's going to get it
and it will go over the fence on the hop
for a ground rule double number 12 on
the year for friend mill race that'll
bring up harold ramirez who's over two
that balls hit hard to left field back
and over the head of guriel up against
the wall that'll get a run home as front
meal scores big herald with an rbi
double
that's his 16th double of the year rbi
number 29 it's a 6-2 ball game
and for ramirez that's a hit now in five
straight games
oh my goodness ryu knocked it down can't
find the ball
and bradley's gonna be safe with an
infield single he's lucky he didn't get
hit in the face with that ball i mean
that was a vicious line drive he got
leather on it
2-2 swinging a miss
mercado down on strikes
ryu will strand a pair
after surgically working through six
brilliant innings
running and that ball is down the third
base line gets past ramirez guerrilla
can come to third and there's contact
there by the shortstop and the umpire
pointing it out
as guriel again base running has been
terrific tonight for the blue jays
george springer opportunity to pour on
more for the blue jays line drive is
caught by ramirez and here comes gurion
home he's going to score i'll tell you
what that was a line drive right at the
left field but gurio read it perfectly
went back quickly and tagged and scored
and there's a terrific cutter down and
away for a swing and a miss as perez
strikes out he has owned that part of
the zone tonight against these righties
down and away
and a 2-2 pitch
curve ball swinging a miss
what a debut for hingin ryu
he has been sparkling through seven
innings
the indians down to their last strike
breaking ball hit on the ground bushet
unloads in a hurry and that's the ball
game ryan burrucking retires the side in
order in the top of the ninth
and abuja's hitters staked engine ryu to
an early lead and he took it from there
he picks up his 11th win of the season
that ties him with chris bassett for the
most wins in the american league